[Music]
hello everyone I'm woman's Grandmaster
subpoena for sure here at the San Luis
chess club and you are going to be
watching games that everyone should know
so before I get started let's see if
anyone would like to guess the player
that I chose for today for today's
lecture yes
you know nobody discussed female chess
players and I think there are a lot of
great games by very strong female chess
players that would be nice to be seen
and known and well I thought I would do
that so I like changes and I think it's
it's nice to support women's chess as
well
and yes I chose Hui fun and Judit Polgar
but first to lead poker and I'm not
quite sure if we'll have the chance to
go over all of the games but I would
like to start with one of Judit Polgar
games so let me ask you first is
everybody familiar with Judit Polgar of
course good so she was one of the
strongest chess players of all time and
she still is I think as a kid I had her
poster next to my bed and there was this
article that came out in in a famous
chess magazine and I I cut it I taped it
next to my bed and that was my
inspiration you know to to try to become
a stronger chess player and she broke a
lot of you know records you know by
becoming the third time one of the
youngest if not the youngest Grand
Master and and she recently I think
three to three years ago she retired
from competitive chess but she still
she's still training the Hungarian chess
team males just him
in all impudent and European
Championships and she's just amazing so
this game was played by her in 1988 so
she played this in the Olympiad and she
played on board too she was 12 or 13
years old when she played this game and
actually she received the prize for four
for the best the best game of the
tournament and it's attacking chess I
chose her because I know how a lot of us
really like attacking chess and she was
a you know she was a great attacking
chess player of course there are so many
great things that I can say so that
let's look at the game let's let the
game speak for itself so you can also
see on the on the screen that she won
the brilliant surprise for her for this
game at the Olympiad and she scored 12
and a half out of 13 and by the way
Hungarian team then female chess team so
there was three plus one I believe three
players plus one alternate they won the
gold medal which which is something that
had never happened in female chess
anyone else then the USSR to actually
win the gold medal in in the Olympiad so
they really broke the polar sisters have
broken a lot of Records so okay so e4 c5
everybody excited about the opening
great night of 396 Bishop e5 okay a lot
of top grandmasters are not they are not
very excited about this this Bishop e5
in general with the other colors but I
think this is this is a pretty cool
dynamic chest especially this game
Castle Bishop g7 C 3 it's pretty clear
what is White's plan next right to play
d4
so black played a five what do we think
what do you guys think about this move
is if I've not so yet typically we don't
see this the c5 being played so much in
this in this move order I think when
white wants to play d4 black typically
plays with the point in d6 leaves this
one in e7 or and tries to play with with
d5 I haven't seen it five played so much
but I'm also not such a big Sicilian
chess player so I might be wrong this
type of system is played with black when
white plays c4 so the English so it's
the bought Vinick system but this way I
was a little bit surprised to see I
think Knight f6 mix is is more popular
here for black any of you that play this
line that can confirm no okay well
anyway so black played e5 what do we
play with white d4 we're talking about a
game that everyone should know it's an
attacking game we're going to open up
open up the center we are going to be
active like you know I wish I could play
this kind of chess
so d4 opening up I mean you know II 5u
black is pushing if you think about it
really
what is this if I've doing good for
black while trying to restrict d4 but
what is doing bad for black is the fact
that ok now the the e-file is is going
to be easily opened well part of it at
least halfway on the key on the file of
where the king is yeah and the king is
not out yet so let's just try to open up
the position especially because we with
white we have finished our develop I
mean we brought our King to safety so if
you have the opportunity to open up the
e-file you know I will try to do it
and Jews it was not I mean from the
interviews that I've seen of her and the
game she doesn't seem that she was ever
fearful of anything and I think in some
interview she even says that she had you
know she was she was not fearful of
anything and in this position black
captured with the e pawn which I think
wasn't really the best choice I would
have gone with the C pawn and then after
take I would have well never mind that
was like I said they could have done the
same
why did I put it in this fashion
I don't remember sorry guys I don't
remember why I said that it's a little
bit better to play to take it with the C
pawn okay probably because I meant that
I think this this is better for black
not capturing with the night I think
that's the reason why I put it there I'm
sorry so basically she takes the force
it takes before it takes d4 and now if
Bishop f4 for example 92 e7 and the idea
is you want to make sure you can castle
so you place your knight here to avoid
some you know Bishop d6 and restricting
of your your castling and then once the
knight is in e7 the black should be
should be fine I think you also because
you have this doubled pawns I mean
currently you have an extra pawn but you
will want at some point to play d5 trade
the pawn and just have a balanced
position and symmetrical but in the game
so you can see black took with the a
pawn and now with the night what to do
here with white what did you do
Bishop c4 one else
ninety-three nice mom
she took well you don't really want to
give this bishop right away and well you
basically gave up a pawn right that was
the reason why we we said earlier if I
was to stop d4 so she's basically giving
up a pawn but she needs to get something
in return and she definitely does not
want to give this bishop out this bishop
in b5 although it's true it could be
easily attacked with a 6 b5 chased away
from there for the moment white needs to
get the initiative when you sacrifice a
pawn you want to gain the initiative to
develop your pieces with tempo and if
you were to waste some time to move the
bishop I think black would simply like
possibly trade like let's see I think I
could possibly trade the knight f6
doesn't work on no or maybe I need to
trade the Queen skin maybe I need to
play something like Queen f6 first or
Queen e7 and then develop my knight
maybe
maybe quean a quean of sex
and okay black will struggle a little
bit but they do have an extra pawn so
but by taking here what do you think
Judas had in mind if Bishop takes d4
huh
25 interesting interesting idea
and let's say I play something like this
it's pretty bad
dynamic just well what do we do here
Bishop g5 you are not scared of
93 is also another option to finish the
development I think there are a lot of
lot of good options here for whitey you
maybe don't need to play e5 to kind of
hang your pawn there maybe you can play
Knight c3 immediately so that you can
actually get the bishop out the next
move if you want to and also you have
this outpost for the moments black
cannot push the deep one and ideas with
a6 b5 I think your bishop will be
recycled that way so anyways black took
it upon moves what you have to apply
here is white
any five
the same kind of idea can you take the
pawn
which one rookie one or Queenie to which
one do we play good and then f4 or
Bishop f4 probably a four it makes more
sense black cannot take the pawns like
this with a king in the center and zero
pieces developed well one piece develop
this bishop in g7 so 97 which was blacks
answer and now you're thinking ok black
will Castle and blacks King is safe
indeed it is now what do we do well we
we cannot really stop like from castling
anymore so it's time to finish our
development Bishop g5 castle and now she
took her pawn back so in this position
if we evaluate the position who is
better why this slightly better more the
pieces are a little bit more developed
but also you know if if black finds a
way to push g6 and trade trade trade
that pawn they would equalize the
position but it's not so simple to push
the deep one right that's why I was
mentioning the other line that I thought
black should have kept the 1966 because
that night was somehow protecting of the
pin so d6 would have and also the
Knights were protecting each other just
imagine black would have had a 1966
protecting the nice protecting each
other it would have been much easier to
push the D pawn but this way you know
it's pretty tough for black
however chillin zero of us so Judith's
opponent found this idea with knight c6
I personally think Knight a5 would have
been slightly better and you'll see you
as the comp as we go onto the game
you'll see why this move is slightly
better the knight is slightly better
placed in f5 and now Queen b6 and well
attack and then I think it's pretty hard
for for--why - stop stop d6 and in
equalizing but maybe black thought the
1966 is going to be placed better
because
well it's developed there normally and
in f5 maybe they said bishop will be
closed and won't be able to get open
then also the 19:6 attacks in five so
maybe you know what black and win
something what do we do of course Queen
h4 that was also not possible that's
that is true that that move was also not
possible but but also with the 19 f5 you
are you're helping your d6 pawn the the
b7 pawn to get to d6 and it's really
important to realize that black once to
get rid of that this is their problem
the point in d7 is their problem because
it's well it's isolated it's restricting
the Bishop from c8 to get out and it's
just restricting also blacks position
like overall because if you don't get
the bishop from CL c8 out then how are
your rooks going to get into play
so it is very important instead black
was a little bit more materialistic I
think girls in general if you look like
female players I think we are more
aggressive but also more materialistic
interests and a lot of us are okay Queen
a 5h4
it's not there's nothing wrong to be
materialistic but you have to try to
compare the different positions that you
would you would get and here unfortunate
it's would wasn't such a great decision
for black Queen b6 what do we do
finishing the development of course 93
and no black blundered by capturing the
pond like I said you know you gotta be
careful
why was the move d5 wanting to get rid
of that pond
now obviously white cannot take here I
think it's pretty obvious why the bishop
know and now I think I can grab a lot of
material where should I take first be 2
or 5 where do you guys think
I would take here first problem
and then your five
plenty of compensation that night might
even remain trapped now we possibly want
quintics anyone hmm
can we take on Poisson why well if we
take back your quintics
but no there's no there's no mate the
Queen the Queen comes you can trade this
one though how does life save yourself
okay so I have a question for you guys
so for example can black play rook e8 is
this yeah Queen f6 okay you won
oopsy gotta be careful who is winning
now so well how do we protect who's
black is this this is clear right white
is is going to checkmate either here or
here or win your queen up to you so how
do we protect with black after Bishop h6
and five pond with
there's no necessity you know to to
weaken your position I mean there's a
threat
the the Rokan and queen have six ideas
but you can also can't you play for
example look here because now if if
Queen f6 now you go Queen to e5 and now
there's no trick on the eighth-ranked
that can still be something but let's
see if it works so for example takes
does it work or no
Quimby cream v5u but if you get super
scared you can also take and something
some peace here no mate right Bishop d7
no mate extra piece yeah so there are a
lot of ways through which through which
black and defend you can also give up
the rook right I mean maybe it's not so
beautiful to place the Queen there but
if you find yourself in difficulty you
can always do things like this if the
Queen's are traded then white can take
but black has sufficient material for
for the rook
so yeah that didn't work but I think
here white could take in c6 context is
six and nine a4 and try to play on the C
file try to improve the position of the
19 C 5 you know White has a slightly
better position because although you
have the pair of bishops your bishops
don't really have such great diagonals
to be placed on and these two pawns
although they might be looking strong if
white men choose to block eight them you
don't do so much this light square
bishop doesn't have such a great agonal
but in the game black to bishop takes e5
what do you do with white let's see if
you can play like Jude it
so we have some candidate moves I hear
95 94 are those good moves pony for rook
e1 which one very good the thing is you
cannot do Knight 95 or 94 you don't
really have a serious threat you're just
giving the bishop up right right right
so it's time to bring another piece to
attack now can you tell me what is
whites thread yes but also not only
Bishop c6 and the rook takes e5 but also
we can also have ideas with sacrificing
the rook only five and then some Bishop
f6 ideas with ideas to try to attack the
King
depending on how black places their
pieces yeah so Bishop c3 was played in
the game was the move played in the game
but I want to see what is happening
after d6 if black tries to protect the
bishop that way what do we do but rook
takes e5 you know there's a reason for
which your Bishop belongs to g7 because
once you take it away from there
you're really weakening your King Kings
position so now rook takes e5 Knight
takes oops and mate is coming i mean
oops
check and or check knight f6 also if I
want another more beautiful one I don't
know which one is more beautiful but
once you get this kind of position with
three pieces attacking and blacks King
restricted over there you can choose
what you like best if you want to make
it Pleasant so yeah so you really need
to be careful here with with black
suddenly you know it's not so defended
anymore why did this happen to black
because they have because she didn't try
to push the D pawn and get her Bishop
out Y has made a lot of moves with
temple and has given up the pawn to be
able to get the pieces more towards the
attack I mean this is this is very hard
to play sometimes because you don't want
to give up material but if you have some
serious ways in which you can attack
your opponent's king go for it so look
remove the defender yeah yeah so black
thought okay at least I'm going to do
stuff with tempo so she took in c3 and
now of course there's no possibility to
attack we don't want to give up material
so we take back technically we did give
up material but what would have what so
in this position black took Queen takes
b5 h5 was another option I want to see
how you would continue your attack
so Bishop takes c6 and Bishop rook e7
okay
Bishop c4 yeah like you can keep your
Bishop for example if you want but why
not this move so now if black takes what
do we do
Queen f6 we're not going for the routine
f8 we're going for the mate and now with
the rookie me 1 you will restrict it
black from from coming back to protect
that King is on the other side of the
board and the mate is there so it's
pretty bad
I think it's there's no difference here
for for for black for this and I really
want to point out some of you mentioned
this move
no please try to keep as many pieces on
the board when you're attacking and also
when you make a trade consider for whom
it is better first of all you have a
bishop and you're trying to give it up
for a knight it's not so I started you
know in order even when I teach kids in
order to try to make them realize the
difference between the two because
there's often they're often taught that
it's fine to put the bishop in b5 and
take the 1966 or put the bishop in g5
take the 19 f6 the bishops are I say
there are three pawns in a quarter
better than the Knights in order to
emphasize and really they are most of
the time so you really have to consider
a hot what are you getting for for that
trade yes your bishop is attacked but
you know also by doing this you're
slowing down a little bit e or your
attack and you would help them like you
guys said to to finish their development
so we don't want to make the trader
better give up the bishop let them spend
some time to grab it and continue with
our attack then take that night okay so
in the game after B takes c3 her
opponent played Queen takes b5
let's hear some continuations here guys
Bishop f6 one any other ideas queen h6
another nice one anything else
rook to e3 okay that one might take a
little bit of time right because maybe
d5 and or d6
okay so we've got Bishop f6 Bishop h6
Queen h6 which one are we going for
I like Queen eight-six because you get
what the Queen coming over to H okay
that's a nice that's a nice decision
everyone is going for Queen h6
Queen h6 should play queen h6
Queen a five-foot black sensor so you
want that five here hmm yeah you can say
oh I skipped not quite and of course
here also it didn't really escape it is
very hard guys if if you have half of
more than half of your pieces on the
other side of the board it's not it's
not going to work and I would like to
also mention okay this is going to bring
up a very strong chess player Levon
Aronian who has just won the san luis
rapid and blitz I had the honor to be
able to talk to him and he showed not
only me but some other strong chess
players a position from that happened in
one of his games and he mentioned to us
that he's talking to his pieces or or
well that the pieces talk to him in the
sense that it might sound strange when
you think of it that way but it's really
like you as you are the one who
basically creates all these strategies
with chess you try to to improve your
position and you really need to make
sure that all your pieces are
coordinated that's one of the you know
the great benefit that we have because
we move them ourselves but we really
have to figure out where where they
better place
and how do we want them to work together
and yeah that just meant so much to me
it just made me realize okay that's
that's great that's a really great
advice I didn't consider it that way you
don't need to make it that personal
maybe but you really need to consider
the coordination of your pieces you
really want them to work together and
here after Queen h6 Queen f5
look before interesting any other ideas
look III okay yeah the same same type of
idea okay
h3 what would be the guys why to move
and win yes Quinta xf8 you know and it's
17 moves okay it's it's a great and she
was a kid she was 13 years old I mean
it's just amazing or 12 12 or 13 I don't
want to say something I think she was
born in 78 so I think she was or wait no
76 76 I'll have to double-check what
she's just below any she was very young
let's just know yes yes but I don't
remember which year exactly 76 or I
think it was 76
so she was 12 years old when she played
this game against a strong player I
think I haven't double-checked the the
Federation for each other opponent
played I think it was Russia I'm not
100% sure I mean in USSR at that point
right and yeah Queen she sacked the
Queen Queen takes f8 now maybe you
understand why I love Queen sacrifices
but anyways well obviously she can try
to bring her rock on the H file and
probably should win that way too but why
wait you have a force meetin why do you
have this mate because Black has not
finished their development these pieces
especially because of this bishop in c8
black simply died with those two pieces
there it didn't talk to them really and
that's the reason why you know from the
stars' okay
after queen f8 her upon
but if we go back to the beginning I had
my my games added here and and I didn't
realize why which is not such a so good
for me but that's the reason why I
wanted black to keep this night in in in
c6 because if the night would have been
here now after night g37 Bishop d6
castle your king is brought to safety
you still have your bishop in g7 you
have the extra pawn which eventually
will be lost but but there won't be
there won't be such a serious attack for
example some games they were played here
white continued Knight bTW to a6 okay
now okay it's just it's a game the game
continues this pawn will be moved the
bishop will be developed it's not so
easy for white to to lead an attack but
taking out the bishop from the
protection of the King too early
has been has been devastating for black
and and the young Judit was able to
completely you know destroy her
opponents so let's let's continue there
is one more game that I have and this is
a longer game and you know that Garry
Kasparov came back too well from
retirement for this tournament in st.
Louis and I felt battled a bit for
choosing this game but a lot of top
players sometimes have stories among
among each other which is kind of fun
for the rest of us to watch but in
another way you know it's not so it's
not so great and and I hope if if
someone from Gary's team will if this
video ever you know will go online I
hope they will not because they will not
be mad with me or something I did ask
for a lot of signatures from him so you
know I feel bad I need to show this but
it I think it's always great to see
a female chess player a role model for a
lot of female chess players to be able
to take down the the world champion this
was just this was a match that was
played between you well typically it was
USSR against the world but they played
this in 2002 so this was just Russia
versus the world and Judy was playing of
course for the world he chose to play he
chose to play the Berlin he chose it
which is a game if some of you are
familiar with the chess history
he lost his title because of the Berlin
opening against kramnik kramnik kept
playing this with black and with black
he he would hold the draw right it's
like a wall and then with white he
managed to win game so this is this was
his opening choice
so garry kasparov went for the berlin
night of six castle takes now d4 night
there takes takes context in any five
Niner five so this is a standard there's
theory till here Queen takes King takes
and Knight c3 so everything is theory
still played nowadays I think at some
point it had a really good reputation
the Berlin then it got a bad one and now
it's again very good for black so if
some of you are thinking of an opening
to choose with black this might be
something you consider now yes a lot of
people want to avoid the Berlin and or
they hear like some people I've seen
some people try to play D 3 or to try to
avoid it but anyways so let's get to our
game so Queen trades Knight c3 and ok
this is not an attacking game but you
can see
that female chess players especially
Judy is also very strong in positional
chess - and n games like all the all
parts of the games of the game are very
important so here
Garry played h6 but more recently people
have played Bishop Bishop d7 and n King
yet if I'm not mistaken with black in
this position but h6 was more popular
than check King e8 and the reason they
play Bishop d7 is that by the way that
the King will go will go on that side of
the board on the Queen side but anyways
h 3 it's pretty clear what White's plan
is right or not to push some g4 change
the night away you're trying to get
space if we look at this position I mean
why is this a playable position because
typically you would say it's much better
for white because white has the majority
on the Kings side right four versus
three that's their plus and blacks
majority on the Queen side is basically
blocked because these pawns are doubled
so with these kind of four versus these
three it's almost impossible to create a
passport unless your opponent is very
nice and just helps you so the plus that
black has is the pair of bishops so
that's that's kind of how things things
are being played here so Bishop e7
Bishop e6 was another move that that has
been tried 92 9 H 4 and again you know
the theory I've added some stuff but we
won't be able to go over all of it more
b6
is another plan for black but in the
game Kasparov played night h4 what do we
do do we train at night or no
centralized or take
take bishop takes well centralized was
nice too I think this idea by the way I
don't want to you know cut you guys off
or something I think this would have
been nice as well
yeah yeah if you want to make a draw
yeah but I don't think Judith I I've
never seen her play for a draw like even
later now before retirement I haven't
really seen her play for a draw I think
she's always had this ambition of
winning so I don't yeah I don't think
she would have gone ninety a stage for
Bishop takes H for Bishop III
development in everything it doesn't
matter what types of openings do you
guys choose to play just make sure you
develop your piece it's really really
important
so here Bishop f5 you know for for fun I
put this move as being a blunder
hopefully all of you realized that this
Bishop remains trapped so that Bishop
will be lost right so do not make a move
like that you have to be careful with
black if you're playing this opening you
don't want to lose pieces so Bishop f5
that's why sometimes it's hard for black
to get their rooks out but also why
doesn't have real activity so anyways 94
and Bishop h7 was played g4 now judith
starts getting her advantage on the
space advantage on the kingside Bishop
e7 what do we do
9:05 somebody said f4 somebody said
which one or f4 interesting
first Bishop here and then maybe a six
and then c5 I want when I chase a night
away from here because it's not an
outpost right I don't want you to get
active and also I want to win your
ponies you do I think if you're not
paying attention on how you push the
pawns you leave that Bishop active
that's not such a great idea in my
opinion understanding this so kingi to
h5 Knight a5 so she prefers to get the
bishop with the trade and to let it
active in e4 it can be really annoying
piece that Bishop so now Gary obviously
doesn't want to take here do you guys
understand why this position is much
better for mints
yeah you'll be able to create your past
poem by pushing e6 at some point and
this Bishop doesn't do it bishop d4
followed by f6 and also look at this
King I mean we see it in the 8th and
we're thinking I really want to castle
but let's not forget the Queen's were
traded so you cannot and now because of
that it's you really are struggling with
the King some that's why some people
like I told you earlier they wanted to
develop the bishop in d7 try to move the
King that way some people do that you
really want a 7 square but you cannot
really get it so Bishop f8 still you
cannot get that is seven square king of
three improving the position white is
simply improving it feels like it's it
feels like she didn't do much other than
improving her the position of her pieces
and I think that's why I also chose this
game because it kind of shows that from
really small small advantage of space
and and a majority on the Kings side you
can you can get such a great
such a great position with white but
okay it's playable for black like I said
there are some other lines Rudy to take
stakes check where do we move the King F
for oh gee - you want to go to F for
mmm can i push f6
and then
maybe trying to take in a five and get
my bishop out if you're pushy six I'm
thinking she won Becky kingi - now King
g3 this is a very nice idea chase the
rook away and then don't let it don't
let it be reactive no activity for the
rook and if we look at black's pieces it
really feels like they don't do anything
now if we play also this move that truck
will not be able to exit f6 Bishop f4
maybe six was could have been slightly
better takes takes rook e1 I like this
move trying to utilize that King so you
still cannot bring your look to d8 I
really think blacks should try to find a
way to get that rock out but as you
could see there's no moment where where
them of worked maybe maybe here instead
of f6 maybe this so what do we do here
with white I think I can take yeah what
do you do you take the King right
no check here first where do you move
your king just to make sure you know why
I give the rook first and not the bishop
to make sure this King doesn't get three
six although it might not matter but
just to make sure it doesn't and then I
want to play a special g5 and it's
impossible to stop that so it's it's
very tough for black so this is kind of
the only way to try to escape the
situation and you know this trade seem
to have been fine for black but now
after rook e1 Bishop takes now if you
take you're losing right because my rook
just takes him somewhere okay this ooh
sorry I'm sorry that was a muscle if
definitely not that one
okay and then
everything falls everything it's it's
terrible
Judit simply kept her position active
and restricted black garyun
what to do so he clicking d7 c4 she is
going for it
c5 takes takes and now I've got a
weakness which you cannot protect so
lucky six okay check and you don't
really have much on this h-file so she
played rock d5 going for the next
weakness check check and the King simply
hides and b6 now obviously if we give
some check here what do we do is with
white
I think so
and now
you 6:35 which 186 I like it six
because if takes you want to take back
with a pawn here have your passport
ready
so mmm disposition he played b6 check
getting the seventh rank and the King is
so strong it now it it will be able to
hide she will be able to hide the king
lukkage - I think against this check
what what would Judith have done what do
you think well there's a move I know for
sure you wouldn't have done King defy
fright she would not have played that
one
yeah but rookie six you know she
activated the the right rogue the
there's a weakness here and these cuts
restrictions on the eighth-ranked are
the worst so just you know no checks
that are helpful rook age for f4 for
example or king e5 and and white is
winning with the F pawn once you lose g7
it's over
so Gary tried to play a little bit more
gage - look they're threatening some
mates check
now we have two mates in both sides of
the board b8 and and g8 king there and I
don't know what happened but okay how is
what does white need to do to win this
just take right then move the you know
you can give check and grabbed up on to
it's over
so this is how she took took down world
champion well former at that point I
think he was not the world champion
anymore so great I hope you enjoyed this
and so next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]